I've watched the Academy Awards for many  many years and the the true emotion that  gushes forth from generally the actors  when they come on but I do have to say  that when Russell Crowe won his award he  was incredibly humble in my opinion and  was talking about the dream of a boy and  how anybody can and sure you know when  you when you grow up in the suburbs of  Sydney or Auckland or Newcastle like  Ridley or Jamie Bell or the suburbs of  anywhere you know a dream like this  seems kind of vaguely ludicrous and  completely unattainable but this moment  is directly connected to those childhood  imaginings and for anybody who's on the  downside of advantage and relying purely  on courage it's possible thanks very  much  that's the message that I get from the  speeches that really affect me is when  somebody feels knows how lucky they are  to be standing there at that moment